si yo te pregunto cuánto es cinco menos
tres más dos cual dirás que es la
respuesta pausa el vídeo e intentar
resolverla muy bien si quieres resolver
esto lo único que necesitas es calcular
de izquierda a derecha primero puede
resolver cinco menos tres y cinco menos
tres es igual a dos y entonces decimos
bien esto es dos más dos que por
supuesto sabemos que es igual a cuatro
bien qué pasará si ahora involucramos
multiplicaciones y divisiones si te
dijera cuánto es 5 más 3 por 2 pausa el
vídeo y resuelve lo
bueno tal vez hayas estado tentado a
hacerlo de una manera similar decide
bien lo haré de izquierda a derecha
primero calculó cuánto es 53 que claro
es lo mismo que 8 y después lo
multiplicó por 2 para así obtener 16
pero resulta que esta no es la forma
correcta de resolver esto ya que por muy
buenas razones que tal vez estudiamos en
vídeos próximos no siempre iremos de
izquierda a derecha sobre todo cuando
estamos trabajando con distintos tipos
de operaciones y la forma estándar para
resolverlo es que la multiplicación y la
división se realizan antes que las sumas
y las restas entonces la forma de
calcular esto será primero realizar 3
por 2 lo cual es 6 entonces esto me
quedaría como 56 lo cual será igual a 11
a 16 entonces esto será igual a 11 bien
con esto en mente hagamos algunos
ejemplos más imagina que te encuentro
por allí y te digo cuánto es nueve menos
seis entre tres pausa el vídeo e
intentar resolverlo bueno como acabamos
de decir primero haremos las
multiplicaciones y divisiones antes de
hacer las restas así que primero haremos
6 entre 36 entre 3 es 2 así que esto se
simplifica a 9 menos 2 lo cual es 7
y quiero hacer énfasis porque esto es
importante quiero que te quedes con la
idea de que la multiplicación y la
división se realizan antes que las sumas
y las restas a menos que se te den otros
tipos de instrucciones porque existe lo
resuelves de izquierda a derecha
tendrías que nueve menos seis estrés el
dividir eso por tres obtenemos uno que
claramente es un número distinto que
siete bien hagamos un último ejemplo
nada más por diversión imagina que
alguien te pregunta cuánto es dos por
tres menos uno pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta bueno en esta
ocasión hacer la multiplicación primero
es lo mismo que empezar a resolver de
izquierda a derecha entonces hacemos
primero 2 por 3 2 por 3 es igual a 6 y
después calculamos 6 menos 1 lo cual es
por supuesto 5
en resumen si tienes muchos números que
se están sumando restando
multiplicando y dividiendo entre ellos y
no tienes paréntesis tenemos que
priorizar la multiplicación y la
división sobre la suma y la resta